Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan
podcast by night all day,
you know,
or things they disagree with.
It's like there's a lot of,
a lot riding on every aspect of fighting.
Like do you see the Bernard Hopkins fight?
Sad,
right.
That was sad.
Bernard Hopkins,
if 51 years old fought this
kid named Joe Smith Jr.
If nobody's seen Joe Smith junior before,
he's fucking,
he's a killer.
Like Bernard Hopkins picked a killer and
this kid fucked him up and his kid has
extra long arms.
He's got weird arms like
his arms go below his waist.
I was watched him fine.
It was like look at the
length of his fucking arms.
Like he just,
he beat the shit out of Bernard and he
knocked him out of the ring and Bernard
caught them with some good shots.
He was timing them and he caught him
with a few right hands with the kid was
just eating them and moving forward.
And you know what it looks like.
It's like when people have fake hands,
like the fake hand is like
sticking through the shirt sleeve.
Yeah.
He almost looked like a cartoon
guy with his extra long arms,
but he's a bad motherfucker.
That guy and Bernard got knocked
through the ropes and fell on his head.
It was crazy to watch and he got up,
he was all disoriented,
didn't know what happened,
thought he was pushed through the ropes,
but he was punched through the ropes
that got connected with like four or five
big shots and,
and the last one was a left hook on the
face as Bernard was going through the
ropes and it knocked
him all the way through,
but it was 100% legal.
He didn't do anything wrong.
He did everything with punches.
It would,
none of it was a push.
He was just bombing on him and
it just was a freak incident.
It's one of the reasons why cages
are so much better than a ring.
A cage is so superior,
like a ring.
It's like that,
that,
that possibility that you
could fall through like that.
That's terrible.
That should,
they should stop using rings
and if they do use rings,
they should pad the shit
out of the outside area.
The fact that someone like Bernard
Hopkins who's been boxing for forever can
still get knocked through a rope like
that and land on his head that that's a
possibility.
That's a stupid way of containing people
they should have instead of ropes like
that would,
they should have is something that has
a criss cross pattern or you can't go
through it and you should have to
just climb over it to get in it.
It should be real simple and it should
be a way that they could release the,
uh,
the ropes.
Like if there was a medical
emergency at the end of the fight,
it should be like a latch.
They could pull and drop the
ribs down and get somebody out.
But the ropes,
the way they use them
now in boxing matches,
they should fucking outlaw those.
The fact that Bernard Hopkins can
get knocked through one like that,
that's,
or the very least,
you've got to protect the outside area.
You got to pad the shit out
of it and you had to have,
he should have people
around and most of the time,
a thousand fights in a row.
It's probably never
going to come into play,
but the one time it does,
you're responsible for that
guy falling through the ropes.
That's fucking stupid.
Like lizard.
He goes flying through men.
Look,
it'll lengthen that kids'
arms so it doesn't look,
it looks Photoshop like his head
is not the right size or something.
He's a,
he's built for it.
I'll tell you that.
He's got great genetics and works hard.
Tough kid.
Really good fighter.
Good Chin Line.
I liked that,
huh?
Yeah,
he's an animal.
I was,
I was super impressed with his poise to
in fighting a guy like Bernard Hopkins.
I mean that guy stepped up in a big way
and he was a two to 100 dog leaning into
that fight,
which is really crazy.
WHATSAPP commit some money on that.
Sure,
yeah.
Yeah.
I was pretty convinced that uh,
Bernard was going to be
able to stifle him and uh,
turn it into like the kind
of fight that Bernard likes.
But I wasn't sure if Bernard could win.
You know,
it's a long time off.
Two years when you're 51 years old.
It's a long time off.
He still fought.
Amazing.
But at the end of the
day that kid marked him,
he just was,
he was just too much and he was,
he's,
he's a guy that would have been a real
threat at any time in anyone's career.
Like he's,
this kid has real talent and right now
he's not thought of as being the best
fighter in the world or
anything even close like that.
But Bernard was at one point in time,
Bernard,
like when he beat Felix Trinidad,
a lot of people were saying that might
be the best pound for pound box or on the
earth.
Like a lot of people thought
Trinidad was going to beat him.
He fucked Trinidad up.
And then he fought Kelly Pavlick and a
lot of people wrote him off against Kelly
Pavlik.
He box the shit out of Kelly Pavlick.
And so you look at like
Bernard's legacy and you go,
man,
this is an unbelievably skillful guy.
But at any point in that career that
Joe Kelly kid would have been a handful,
he's just scary.
He's,
or Joe Smith,
rather,
that Joe Smith junior kid would have
been a handful because he's just fucking
scary.
He hits hard and he's,
he's super accurate and he's got awesome
endurance and a great work ethic.
He's fucking dangerous
no matter what era it is.
And Bernard,
you know,
maybe Bernard would have
been able to beat him in his,
in his prime.
You know,
it's totally possible.
It's 100% likely.
I mean,
Bernard's and all time.
Great.
Maybe it would have been able to land
more of the punches that he landed in that
fight.
But you don't know.
I mean,
that kids,
dangerous boxing,
such a crazy sport.
[inaudible].